hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from round seven of the
2018 Greinke chess classic here we have
a game between Maxim Bashir Alegre and
Fabiano Caruana and I think this game
will perfectly illustrate is Fabi ready
for November or not well to some degree
but I don't have any any photos as of
yet but I might have I might have some
photos for you tomorrow we will see so
let's let's just dive straight into this
game Fabi if are we still in the lead in
this tournament although he's tied with
Maxime holograph so definitely
definitely this could be the game that
that might decide the winner of the
tournament although there are still
rounds to go this round seven so two
more rounds so Maxime opens with c4 the
English opening we have E 5 Knight to c3
Knight to f6 and Knight to f3 Knight the
c6 so the four Knights variation of the
English g3 Bishop to b4 and Bishop to G
- we have castles castles and E for now
Knight to g5 Bishop captures on c3 pawn
captures on c3 and rook to e8 Queen to
c2 piling up on that efore pawn and
quinta c2 is a reasonable move Fabi says
that he was he was definitely expecting
either f3 or or d3 but f3 and e3 are are
extremely highly theoretical moves so
you have to really really know what
you're doing if you decide to play this
and if Abby was ready for this and he
says Queen to c2 is just you know a
reasonable move and I don't think I will
be putting any interviews in the
description below I since I don't think
there will be any interviews with the
players about this game but if you if
you check it out there will be like an
entire coverage of around 7:00 so you
can just first fast-forward to the part
where were Peter and Indiana are
interviewing Fabi it's not like an
official interview where there's like a
close-up of either of them but you know
he will analyze some moves it's ok Queen
to c2 now comes d5 see capture some d5
Queen capture some d5 and d3 so again
going for that e4 pawn as you can't
capture as the bishop is eyeing the
Queen and if I
so Bishop to a5 we have Bishop to f4 now
attacking the c7 point and now h6 Knight
captures on e4 Knight captures on e4 and
now Queen to be two going to be two
there are a lot of moves possible in
this position for example you could
immediately capture the the piece back
Bishop captures Bishop captures Queen
captures Queen captures rook captures
Bishop captures on c8 and after you kick
the Bishop back you grab on e2 and white
didn't really accomplish anything here
if anything black is better as White's
pawn structure is a bit messed up here
he has three point islands black has two
so definitely advantage for black so
after after this move Fabi said that
during the game he didn't really
calculate this too much he was expecting
maybe c-4 to come but then Queen to be
two was played and he didn't think much
of this move he defended the b7 point he
played b6 and here again he thought
about Bishop captures on c7 what if then
rotate to c8 again kicking the bishop
back and then Knight to a5 and he
thought that this was this was this was
pretty good for black that he would have
compensation as he's piling up here on
the weak c3 pawn and after white
captures back as he does have to for
example Bishop captures Bishop captures
Queen captures it's definitely a nice
compensation again piling up here on D
point the c3 ponies with the ape on his
weak so again again Fabi thought that
this was okay so never really worried
about this c7 point but here rook F the
d1 was played and we have Queen to c5 d
captures on e4 Bishop captures on e4 and
now Bishop to f1 Bishop to f1 you don't
really want to capture you could capture
honey for all our rook captures and then
again you don't really gain anything by
grabbing this but there was a reasonable
idea I have kuru captures the rook to d7
of getting a lot of activity here for
white but but maxime didn't didn't think
this was worth it obviously so after
Bishop captures any for Bishop to f1 so
now after this Bishop moves the e2 point
will be
tected we have rook to e7 Fabia is
preparing to double up on the file a for
now and rook 88 and the far we said that
he really liked this a for move but next
move
maxime plays and Bobby says that that he
maybe he kind of missed the idea because
he liked either a four or rock a to see
one but a four and then rotate to see
one that this is kind of mixing two
ideas into one so here five played g5
giving the bishop back Bishop to d2 and
now Queen to f5 we have F 3 and F 3 is F
3 is a mistake but there's really there
really isn't a better move other than F
3 here after every file we played Queen
to c5 check and he thinks that Maxine
missed this while he played f3 because
now you can't go King to g2 King to g2
losses on the spot to Bishop captures on
f3 this comes with check you capture and
now you get to the terrible rook to e to
check Bishop captures rook captures you
move the King and now Queen to f2 and
there is no defense whatsoever against
Queen captures on h2 or queen - G -
checkmate
now or even yeah ok a lot of checkmates
here and another interesting thing is
after this Bishop captures on f3 you
can't even capture with the King because
now Queen to g1 is deadly not allowing
the King to come back and now well I
mean you have a kingdom f3 that's that's
bad bet in itself but it's actually a
forced checkmate for example whatever
wise plays you can open up an attack on
the black queen maybe try something
there but now simply Knight to d5 check
King goes up the board f5 check you have
to you have to capture now Queen f2
check you block simply rook a faith
check King goes back captures captures
captures with the Queen King to d5 and
now Queen to c4 of a very nice checkmate
so a beautiful King hunt and this might
be what maxime missed after Queen to c5
that he couldn't play King to g2
if he saw that he might figure out a
different plan other than f3 so he
played King to h1 but now Bishop to d5
and
White's position is simply terrible all
of blacks pieces are extremely active
the roofs are beautiful here whites
pieces are completely passive down their
whites Queen side pawns are weak so
Bishop to e1 and here we have Bishop to
c4 now with the triple attack on the d2
pawn on d2 one here efore was played
Bishop captures on f1 and now you have
two you do have to play this to open up
an attack on the piste to capture it and
while he do get the piece back after
Queen to c4 rook captures you lose
another point on the Queen side so now
it's three against one on the Queen side
this is pretty pretty terrible for white
c4 was played Knight to e5 Bishop to b4
g4 now pawn captures and now Queen to d7
Queen to c3 c5 Bishop captures rook
captures and Queen to f3 kind of kind of
pressuring that F 7 square root captures
on e4 so grabbing yet another pawn rook
C 2 D 1 attacking the Queen and now
Queen to e6 and now with this powerful
battery and e-file there's really
nothing white can do here it's simply
the position on the Queen side is
completely winning for black so all
black really has to do is is exchange
pieces so g6
g5 trying to open up some lines of
attack H captures we have rook to d5 g4
now by 5e Queen to c3 Rupe 25 and after
up to e5 in this position maxime
beaugeois graphic design/credits there
there isn't anything a white that hope
for here except for maybe a blunder but
as Fabi is the World Chess Championship
challenger I don't think I don't think
he wouldn't miss a move like this
so after up to e5 Maxime share allegra
resigned the game as there's really
nothing to hope for here if you exchange
we already said this there's really no
no point in playing this position
with two points down it's completely
winning position for black and even if
you try something like moving the rook
to keep the game going
it's simply too easy to exchange for
black well I can simply and give a check
here and after King moves now rook to
eat - you threaten checkmate and white
has to exchange some pieces here
captures captures again you threaten
checkmate and after roof - f2 again you
have to capture capture and now you're
it's a queen and ponent game where black
is up two points but you don't even have
to play this you can simply give Queen
f3 trick you can give up one point but
after Queen captures and King captures
on f3 and now you're only one point off
but completely winning after h6 and b5
there's really nothing white white can
do here so yeah very nice after this
rook to e5 maxime resigned the game like
we said and an excellent victory for
Fabiano Caruana who is now in clear
first in the grand HS classic and two
more rounds to go until the end of the
tournament I will show you one more game
from this round at least one more so I
will include the standings in that video
so I don't spoil anything in this one so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos Sierra thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
with another game from the cranky chess
classic